since president Trump's election victory
we've heard experts proclaiming that it
was Trump's blue-collar appeal that led
him to the win free trade left Americans
in Rust Belt states behind Trump
promised to quash that free trade
government subsidies went only to the
areas beyond the horizon Trump promised
to bring them back a solid mix of
democratic redistribution ISM and
protectionism brought these voters home
to the Republican Party but now a new
study says the real reason so many white
blue-collar workers went for Trump had
nothing to do with their hillbilly elegy
economic status instead the data show
that these voters were simply alienated
by the cultural myopia of Democrats who
have focused an intersectionality Laden
definition of American politics labeling
straight white men the bad guys in their
bizarre morality play according to PRI
the Atlantic a new model has been
developed to measure the five most
significant factors leading to support
for Trump among white working-class
voters the first was obvious
identification with the Republican Party
but the second was fear of cultural
displacement the data showed that white
working-class voters who say they often
feel like a stranger in their own land
and believe the US needs protecting
against foreign influence or 3.5 times
more likely to favor Trump than those
who did not share these concerns this is
where the Democratic Party has truly
gone off the rails by trotting out
Hollywood celebrities who's arrived
flyover America as a bunch of
bible-thumping simpletons more and more
Americans feel alienated inside their
own country and no Lena Dunham speeches
and Laverne Cox diatribes that are going
to reverse that in fact the more Dunham
and Cox are thrust to the floor by
Democrats the more people will vote
Republican in Michigan Wisconsin Ohio
and Pennsylvania
the third factor in the study support
for deporting immigrants living in the
country illegally voters who support a
deportation were 3.3 times more likely
to express a preference for Trump than
those who do not this was an Coulter's
thesis and it was right people feel that
the culture is changing in the United
States not only due to the acidic effect
of leftism but due to the left's overt
desire to change American culture
through unfettered immigration without
concern for assimilation workers in Ohio
aren't all that concerned about losing
their jobs to illegal immigrants but
they are concerned about losing their
country to people coming from lands that
do not share the same basic values the
fourth factor disdain for higher
education again this is a cultural
hallmark not an economic one according
to PR I quote white working-class voters
who said that college education is a
gamble
we're almost twice
is likely to express a preference for
Trump as those who said it was an
important investment in the future that
has less to do with people to standing
an engineering degree then people seeing
that liberal colleges have become
breeding grounds for anti-american
globalism and anti traditionalism the
notion that these blue-collar workers
were deeply concerned with trade and
subsidies is belied by the fact that the
fifth factor evaluated under this study
economic hardship actually correlated in
reverse fashion with Trump voting quote
being in fair or poor financial shape
actually predicted support among white
working-class Americans rather than
support for Donald Trump these people
the people the media have suggested were
completely taken in by Trump's
man-of-the-people shtick
we're actually 1.7 times more likely to
support Hillary Clinton all of which
suggests that the call from moderate
Republicans to embrace democratic
economics is a fool's errand and that
dumping the Reagan combination of social
conservatism and free markets won't
actually guarantee a winning combination
in the Rust Belt trumpism is less about
Trump than about rejection of Obama ISM
in clintonism and that is a very good
thing for conservatism and for America
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
all right you want to get to the latest
from the Yates clapper hearings that
happened yesterday we're also going to
be talking about some amazing comments
from Condoleezza Rice we'll be talking
about the latest on Trump care and Jimmy
Kimmel and all the rest of it but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at my Patriot supply so right now
there's a lot of talk about North Korea
and the threat of North Korean nuclear
missiles reaching American shores
sometime in the near future well if that
happens you're certainly going to want
to be somebody who has an emergency food
supply on hand or if you're just worried
in general about the possibility of
natural disaster if you worried the
federal government sucks at its job
which you should be since they do then
you need to go to prepare with been calm
prepare with been calm eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen and get
your four-week emergency food supply for
just 99 bucks plus free shipping four
week emergency food supply people the
office of States's they say that it
tastes like home cooking and it lasts
for years so you don't have to worry
about buying it new every year you buy
it once you forget about it and then you
remember it when the zombie apocalypse
happens prepare with been calm eight
eight eight eight o 31413 888 803 1413
most states have some sort of disaster
warning system and most of them say that
you're supposed to have some food on
hand in case something goes back here in
California we obviously worry about
earthquakes and people are supposed to
have a certain amount of canned food in
their house or at least preserved food
in their house my parents supplies
preserved food they make sure that you
have good tasting food if disaster
should strike again it's a four-week
emergency food supply for just 99 bucks
ninety-nine bucks plus free shipping
prepare with been calm you're going to
want to make sure you have that
long-term emergency foods plan had
ninety-nine bucks is not a lot of money
to guarantee safety for you and your
family okay so the big story of the day
yesterday was of course the Yates
clapper hearing so Sally Yates was the
former acting Attorney General under
Attorney General Sessions she was there
for a very short period of time because
he recused himself in the Trump Russia
investigation and then she had said that
she was not going to defend the Obama
the the Trump executive order with
regard to refugees with regard to travel
ban and he fired her for good reason so
she's coming back now and she's
testifying and she's testifying because
the Democrats think she has secret
information linking Trump to the
Russians James clapper who is the head
of the intelligence agencies under
Barack Obama he was also called before
Congress
to testify about the supposed Trump
Russia connections and there was nothing
new really as far as the Trump Russia
connection so the idea that there was
all sorts of new material being broken
about Trump and Russia that suddenly
they dropped a bombshell that said that
Trump was indeed colluding with the
Russians in order to fix the election
that didn't happen that led President
Trump to do what I thought was actually
the most suspicious thing about Trump
Russia connections that I've seen and
that is he changed the header on his
entire Twitter feed so President Trump
has at what is it 24 25 million Twitter
followers at this point on this
particular account you know a stunning
number of people follow president from
on Twitter and he changed the entire
header on his on his on the top of his
Twitter feed he changed it again this
morning to remove the tweet but
yesterday he had this picture of him
with the entire Congress basically and
then it said director clapper reiterated
what everybody including the fake news
media already knows there is no evidence
of collusion between Russia and Trump
that's what it said on the top of his
Twitter feed now if that doesn't sound
suspicious to you that's because you've
never heard of the Streisand effect the
Streisand effect of course is named
after Barbra Streisand
she apparently wanted to keep the beach
in front of her house clear of her for
her view and so she had tried to stop
people from building in front of her
house even though she's obviously super
rich and can afford to drive down to the
ocean and she made a big fuss over
people finding out about that she sued
some news outlet and this of course made
a huge story the strike sound effect
applies here to when this is sort of the
equivalent of Richard Nixon putting I am
NOT a crook at the top of his Twitter
page it's just not smart even if it's
true it's just not smart all the way
through he was tweeting incessantly
about Yates yesterday he said the rush
of Trump collusion stories a total hoax
when will this taxpayer-funded charade
and biggest story today between clapper
and Yates's on surveillance why doesn't
the media report on this hashtag fake
news Sally eighths made the fake media
extremely unhappy today she said nothing
but old news well it's not totally true
that she said nothing but old news she
sort of confirmed some stuff that we
already knew which is true but the fact
is that it's a mistake for Trump to be
commenting publicly about the sort of
thing because all it does is drive more
attention it makes people feel like the
lady doth protest too much
in any case Sally H is testifying before
Congress yesterday and here was sort of
the big
News portion of what she had to say is
that Mike Flynn the national security
advisor and she's obviously been called
in because she was the person who
supposedly warned the Trump
administration that Mike Flynn was in a
compromising position because Flynn had
been paid by the Russians and he had
been talking to the Russians and
therefore he couldn't be trusted with
national security secrets here was
Elliot's we weren't the only ones that
knew all of this that the Russians also
knew about what general Flynn had done
and the Russians also knew the general
Flynn had misled the vice president and
others because in the media accounts it
was clear from the vice president and
others that they were repeating what
general Flynn had told them and that
this was a problem because not only did
we believe that the Russians knew this
but that they likely had proof of this
information and that created a
compromised situation a situation where
the National Security Adviser
essentially could be blackmailed by the
Russians so this is what people are
latching on to on the left today was
that Flynn was compromised she told the
Obama the Trump administration that
Flynn was compromised and then they
waited 18 days to fire Flynn they
around they pretended that nothing was
wrong and so this has created some
serious questions about why they didn't
fire Flynn earlier and those questions I
think are legitimate I don't think
that's an illegitimate question once you
inform somebody that there's a member of
your team who might be compromised by
foreign intelligence services it seems
to me that you'd want to move a little
bit faster than three weeks on that sort
of thing
it is not proof however that Trump was
colluding with the Russians and in fact
there really is no evidence of collusion
James clapper who is the head of the
intelligence agencies under Obama he
came forward and he said that there was
no real evidence of collusion or at
least that he had none this is that
kleptos community assessment concluded
first the President Putin directed an
influencer campaign to erode the faith
and confidence of the American people in
our presidential election process second
that he did so to demean Secretary
Clinton and third that he sought to
advantage mr. Trump these conclusions
were reached based on the richness of
the information gathered and analyzed
and were thoroughly vetted and then
approved by the directors of the three
agencies and me okay so he comes forward
he says that there really is no evidence
that he is seen
th-then tries to walk that back a little
bit and this is what the media are
hanging their head on today because
Trump is hanging his hat on the clapper
comments here that there is no evidence
of collusion the media are hanging their
hats on the on the idea that clapper
didn't know about an FBI investigation
those ongoing into possible collusion
hersel eh saying that yesterday if I
could try to clarify one answer before
as well because I think Senator Graham
you may have misunderstood me you asked
me whether I was aware of any evidence
of collusion and I declined to answer
because answering would reveal
classified information I believe that
that's the same answer that director
Comey gave to this committee when he was
asked this question as well and he made
clear and I'd like to make clear that
just because I say I can't answer it
you should not draw from that an
assumption that that means that the
answer is yes okay fairness I think if I
may sir that this illustrates what I was
trying to get at in my statement about
the unique position that the FBI FBI
straddles between intelligence and law
enforcement I just want the touchiered
you know that whatever they're doing on
the counterintelligence side mr. clapper
didn't know about it didn't make it in
the report
and we'll see what comes from it miss
chase what did you tell the White House
about mr. Flinn I had two in-person
meetings and one phone call with the
White House Counsel about mr. Flint the
first meeting occurred on January 26 I
called Don Magan first thing that
morning and told him that I had a very
sensitive matter that I needed to
discuss with him that I couldn't talk
about it on the phone and that I needed
to come see him and he agreed to meet
with me later that afternoon okay and so
knew what she was saying no she's
denying what clapper had said which is
that he saw no evidence of collusion so
Yates is saying there might be evidence
of collusion but that's classified it
the way that Trump solves all of this is
by just D classifying the material right
Trump is the president of the United
States has the capacity to declassify if
you wants to declassify the material he
certainly can and he probably should at
this point if you want all of this to
come to an end it's a very weird
situation where you have members of the
intelligence community who are basically
coming forward and creating the
appearance of smoke without any evidence
of fire and that's what
happening here Sally a - obviously is a
political figure she it makes a bunch of
political points in this particular
testimony she went at it with senator
Cruz over the travel ban and people were
saying that she destroyed Cruz over the
travel ban she didn't she was citing a
different provision of law than Cruz was
citing that is the entire legal debate
over the travel ban she is a political
actor to pretend that Sally Yates is not
a political character is just silly
James clapper also is a political actor
but this is why it's sort of dangerous
number one have political actors and
positions of power and intelligence they
have the ability to see intelligence
that we don't see and number two then to
question them in an open forum because
what you end up with is a situation
where they say well we have a secret but
we can't tell you and all that does it
leads people to believe that there's
something nefarious going on without any
actual proof of anything nefarious going
on now remember no matter what Sally
Yates said here or what clapper says
here no evidence has actually been
presented of collusion between Trump and
Russia surrounding this election cycle
that doesn't seem to matter to the media
they're jumping on the idea that Yates
is not willing to just say there's no
evidence to say well that means there
must be evidence well it works both ways
I mean if it's classified material
what's possible that she can say she
can't say that there's no evidence
because it's still in the process of
investigation so again the sort of the
sort of politicization of intelligence
is really really dangerous it's been
happening under Obama it's now happening
under Trump and and it's not leading
people to have any confidence in these
agencies if Trump really wants all of
this to go away he should be moving
swiftly to have his people going through
whatever intelligence they have security
to see and security clearance to see and
then reveal it as fast as possible
because the American people do have a
right to know about all of this stuff
now the stuff that Trump does want to
focus on is the stuff with regard to
unmasking so you remember the case that
Trump was making with regard to the
intelligence community is that well
Yates and clapper may be focused on Mike
Flynn being complicit with the Russian
gang and well they may be concerned
about front brush inclusion while that
may be the priority of the left the
priority of the right is that the the
Obama administration was unmasking Trump
officials in an attempt to basically
target them for leaks so the idea would
be that they saw a communication that
was masked and it said something like
Russian ambassador Sergei kis lyac was
having a conversation with unnamed
American citizen one an unnamed American
citizen one said acts and so the obama
administra
okay we want to know the name of unnamed
American citizen one and then we can
leaked it to the press that's the
accusation that Trump is making anyway
both the a-10 clapper yesterday admitted
to viewing unmasked Trump campaign and
communications meaning that they saw
materials that had members of Trump's
name his team's names on them that's not
illegal by the way but it is a problem
when you have Susan Rice and members of
the Obama administration going out of
their way to deliberately unmask only
American citizens associated with the
Trump campaign that is the big debate
and we'll see both sides of it here
here's Chuck Grassley did either of you
ever review classified documents in
which mr. Trump his associates or
members of Congress had been on masks oh
yes you have can you give us details
here and there's no intent may shades
have you yes I have and no I can't give
you details okay and she's obviously
very happy about not be able to give
details because she doesn't want to give
details obviously clapper then went on
and he said that you know to pretend
that it was just about Trump campaign
being unmasked lots of people get
unmasked under under this under the way
the law works my former office publishes
a report on the statistics of how many
US persons identities are on mass based
on a collection that occurred under
section 702 of the FISA Amendment Act
which I'll speak to in a moment and in
2016 that number was 1934 so here is the
takeaway we don't know we don't know
more today than we did yesterday in fact
in some ways you know what today then
yesterday the rationale being that on
the one side as I say the right is
trying to claim there's no Trump Russia
collusion and then you have Sally Hayes
saying well there might be material
there but I can't talk about it because
it's classified so we don't actually
learn anything there there's a lot of
smoke for the left to play with but no
fire on the other side you have the
right saying the Obama administration
unmasked all these members of the Trump
team they apparently wanted a fights of
warrants against a member of the Trump
campaign presumably Carter page and the
left is saying well we unmasked lots of
people so again smoke no fire so lots of
smoke everywhere and no fire again this
is the problem when intelligence becomes
politicized because there really is no
way once the intelligence is politicized
for anyone to trust what's coming out of
the intelligence community absent masty
classification and that's probably
unfortunately what has to happen here
now because no one trusts the
intelligence services all the way
through the the other story that was
being pushed by the left very hard
yesterday was the story that said that
Obama had warned the Trump
administration about the dangers of Mike
Lynn that Mike Lynn was actually
compromised by the Russians no evidence
that Obama actually warned Trump about
this before Trump nominated Flynn to
become NSA and in fact the the Trump
administration basically said that Obama
didn't like Flynn personally and that's
why he was complaining about Mike Flynn
Sean Spicer came out yesterday and and
he talked about what Obama had actually
said to Trump about Mike Flynn
the president doesn't disclose details
of meetings that he has which in this
case was a hour-long meeting but it's
true that the president made it
President Obama made it known that he
wasn't exactly a fan of general Flynn's
which is frankly shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone that given that
general Flynn had worked for President
Obama was an outspoken critic of
President Obama's shortcomings
specifically as it related to his lack
of strategy confronting Isis and other
threats around that were facing America
so the question that you have to ask
yourself really is if President Obama
was truly concerned about general Flynn
why didn't he suspend general Flynn
security clearance which they had just
remonster earlier
additionally why did the Obama
administration let Flynn go to Russia
for a paid speaking engagements even fee
there were steps that they could have
taken that if that was truly a concern
more than just a person that didn't had
bad blood okay and that's exactly
correct good for Sean Spicer for calling
it out the media headline yesterday that
it was such a disaster that Obama had
warned Trump and Trump didn't take the
morning a lot of us warning that Flynn
wasn't a good pick that's not the same
as saying here's some specific
intelligence saying that Flint has been
compromised by the Russians for the
stupidest reaction to all of this we can
always turn to our good friend Chris
Matthews over on MSNBC man comes over
they show up in the morning those are
they show come on in there talk about
Trump Russia yay you know I 88 doesn't
Yates because Yates a political hack v8
is a girl that's what I think go Trump
wants Monday May 8 2017 well today
Donald Trump found himself against a
prosecutor who should scare the
daylights out of him I'm talking about
Sally Yates the former acting Attorney
General who dared
blow the whistle twice in his face first
he informed Trump's Whitehouse lawyer
that the director of national security
might be up to his neck with the
Russians the second strike was calling
out his victorious Muslim ban as a
violation of the First Amendment which
spans the government from recognizing an
official religion and both those charges
by yates against Trump make him look bad
make her look very good it could be the
last part making Sally Yates look good
that's driving the man in the White
House up a wall remember how a senator
Elizabeth Warren once wonderfully put it
he can't stand the fact that he's losing
to a girl okay and so I love that
everything for the left always comes
back down to that same argument about
how Republicans hate women and they
can't stand losing to a girl and all of
this routine and then they wonder why
Trump won Trump won mainly because of
stuff like this from Chris Matthews just
silliness okay so I want to talk about
the latest on Trump care I want to talk
things I like condi rice did something
amazing today that I want to talk about
and some things that I hate as well but
for all of that you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire.com become a
subscriber $8 a month gets you
subscriptions you daily wire.com if you
want an annual subscription then you can
buy that over there and you get a free
copy of the Arroyo border film set on
this and on the southern border
fictional film it's an action Western
about a rancher who's trying to defend
his land from people who are attempting
to cross it from drug cartels really
good movie go over to Daley wire calm
right now and become a subscriber for
that you can watch the rest of the show
live in a couple of days you can be part
of the mailbag we only answer your
questions if you're part of the mailbag
so if you want to be one of the lucky
few go over to Daley wired.com right now
and subscribe or if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and download the show
subscribe and make sure that you leave
us a review over in iTunes we always
appreciate it this is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]